mais où va l'eau le mot sapiens comme
animal pensant si vous voulez comme nina
le pensant comme animal tout court il a
sign se casse pas trop vite
quelques dizaines de milliers d'années
avait à vivre encore avant d'être un
homo super sapiens ou ultra sapiens nous
verrons le même corps que les derniers
néanderthaliens pratiquement et le même
cerveau que les hommes de cro magnon et
nous avons su se construire par
accumulation de symbole tout le monde
autour de nous et tout le tout le monde
de la mécanique tout le monde de la
haine de l'industrie et c'est le même
homme qui est actuellement dans les
usines qui se trouvait au milieu des
steppes au paléolithique et cette
disproportion entre les moyens dont
dispose l'homme et ses aptitudes
physiques et intellectuelles et la chose
qui me frappe le plus dans ce chapitre
de la liberté imaginaire auquel vous
faites allusion
le contact entre l'homme et la nature
devient de plus en plus étroits et
difficiles ce qui le monde pour lequel
nous avions participé pendant plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'années était un
monde où le la partie de la nature
n'était pas une partie perdue et où
l'homme jouait avec la nature sans là
sans la casser
actuellement nous avons éloigner la
nature des individus de là
il ya des millions d'hommes qui vivent
maintenant dans un monde totalement
urbanisées et artificielle et du même
coup nous nous sommes en train de
liquider les dernières girafes les
derniers éléphants les derniers lyon les
dernières baleines et nous sommes en
train de créer un monde qui sera un
monde totalement dénué de ce qui faisait
à mon sens l'équilibré des activités de
l'homme paléolithique et l'homme
combien de temps arrive encore de cette
manière je ne peux pas vous répondre
parce que on peut faire une
extrapolation biologique et dire que si
nous continuons dé voc d'évoluer à la
vitesse à laquelle on évolue et nos
ancêtres il ya plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'années avant que nous soyons
autre chose que l'homo sapiens
mais dans ce champ de plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'années
tout peut arriver du jour au lendemain
ou d'une seconde à l'autre
vous faites allusion à la bombe atomique
il en allusion pas spécialement à la
bombe atomique mais à tous ceux qui nous
nous aurons consommer notre monde avant
d'avoir changé l'espèce humaine
oui parce que en fait l'avenir de
l'homme certains le conçoivent bien sûr
dans 50 ou 100 ans vous êtes à l'échelle
paléontologique c'est à dire environ de
toute façon moins cinq cent mille ans et
tout d'un coup les problèmes
sociopolitiques humain dispard est bien
oui j'ai simplement le sentiment que
nous risquons du zèle à terre avant
d'avoir terminé notre propre trajectoire
par une méconnaissance de nos
possibilités
pas un parent par gaspillage je trouvais
un peu pessimistes dont me trouviez
pessimiste mais c'est que je ne suis pas
pessimiste c'est le déroulement des
faits historiques qui peut donner
une interprétation pessimiste je crois
que on pourrait encore alors que le
monde extérieur est encore sauvable que
la nature est encore plus temps peut
encore être être sauvés de la
catastrophe et en particulier les
espèces animales
je pense qu'on pourrait si on en faisait
l'effort étant donné le fait que les
loisirs des individus iront en
augmentant au cours des décennies qui
viennent on pourrait faire l'effort de
revin de cultiver notre notre milieu
naturel et de donner aux individus la
possibilité de fréquenter le monde des
arbres des oiseaux et pas seulement les
souterrains d'une cliente cité futuriste
ce qu'il a des espèces animales qui ont
disparu il ya de nombreuses espèces
animales qui sont enfin il ya des idiots
parmi les mammifères d'assez nombreux
mammifères qui n'existe plus dans les
parcs zoologiques
il s'est planté un coup avec lee
biologique de l'homme je crois que oui
je crois que oui
la meilleure preuve qu'on puisse tirer
c'est là la faim et la soif des
individus pour des pour les questions
naturelles pour le pour le lointain
passé de la liberté l'homme
préhistorique pour le les échappés dans
la nature les élèves la pratique de la
spéléologie ou de la montagne
tout ça ce sont des ce sont des
réactions saines et profonde de l'homme
qui se débat au milieu d'un
un milieu artificiel où ils ne trouvent
pas la satisfaction que son équilibre
[Musique]